We want to talk about some issues things
about Mimi and a cab who's been
manifesting and now Daniel Pikachu. He's
livid and irate. He tried to go after
David Wood and now he's doing a stream
because I saw he's doing a stream about
me. They're livid. Over 1 million views.
They're livid. They're irate because the
Lord Jesus Almighty used interview to
dis Islam, expose Islam, which is why
Mimi Nab manifested. So I'm going to
give you a little details.
Let me remind you, Mimi Nikab, I will
obliterate and destroy you
intellectually.
I will end your career by the power of
Jesus Christ, God Almighty. Muhammad's
God and judge as Jesus ended Muhammad's
life and sent him to Muhammad is on the
feet of Jesus. You're a joke. You're a
fraud. You won't last more than 10
minutes. I promise you, you won't.
That's my promise. And Daniel Pikachu, I
already destroyed you once. I'll bury
you again by the power of Jesus Christ.
Your jokes, your clowns.
God bless me to know how to destroy your
fake religion and there's nothing you
can do about it. All you can do is
threaten to and us. But even if we die,
we live forever because Jesus almighty
and we won't be in that's where Muhammad
is. He's under feet of Christ. So you
guys are now livid and manifesting.
So let me tell you what happened. When I
accepted to debate Mimi and Nikab,
he went live. He started foaming,
manifesting like Muhammad did. I need
you to listen now. We're going to begin.
Now, guys, I'm going to try not to cuss
people out. If I fail, forgive me
because you see they're manifesting
already. And it's hard. May the spirit
reign me in. Okay? But please don't be
offended if I call these pagan
Muhammadans what they are. Stone
kissers, pagans, jihadis.
That's true. That's what they are. And
no, I'm not bashing David Wood. That's
not what I'm doing.
I'm going to defend David, not that he
needs me, okay? Because I want to show
you something about David and I. See,
David and I have a standard. Our
standard is Jesus Christ, our Lord.
So, he is the standard by which to judge
us. So, when we do something,
you can then judge us whether we're
living up to that standard or not. But I
want to show you that David Wood and I
when we failed the standard of the Lord,
we were actually behaving like good
Muslims.
We were behaving like good Muslims.
Okay, you ready? Because now I'm going
to turn it against Muhammad A. Now you
get ready. Let's get into it. I may have
to go sit on my couch. Now I'm going to
show you. Okay. Only thing David did
that was a mistake. only thing he did
one mistake he made he should not have
mentioned brother I know you're watching
me you should not have mentioned what
you did
that was your past you are not a
Christian you are now forgiven you're a
new creation in Christ you're under the
blood of Christ the only problem is
though you're forgiven
the Muslims and those who hate you
are going to use that because of the
legal system let me repeat sit if you
guys don't Right? I have that light
open. Let me repeat.
Christ has forgiven David and may he
forgive me. He's a new creation. But men
are not Christ. They do not care. You're
forgiven. They'll still come after you.
And the Muslims are doing all they can
to now get David Wood into trouble
legally. See, this was the problem.
There was no need for you to mention
that. None whatsoever. But it is what it
is. It's out there. There's nothing we
can do about it. So, you need to pray
for him. God will protect him. Bless his
wife, a wonderful woman. I pray Marie
Wood still prays for me to be a true
Christian. And I finished the race.
Wonderful family. Wonderful. I was there
two weeks. I lived in their house. I was
in their house for two weeks. Okay.
She is a Look, I I got to be honest
because I we can't bear false witness,
right? May God purify my motives. We
can't bear false witness. She is a
wonderful woman. Wonderful woman. I have
love and respect for her. She is a godly
woman. May God bless her. May the Lord
heal her heart. I hope she doesn't hate
me. May she pray for me to be a
Christian. You know, she thinks I'm not
a Christian. I hope I am. I really do. I
don't want to die under the wrath of
Christ. I don't. Okay. But now
let me now put things in perspective.
One of the reasons I suspect one of the
reasons I suspect
No, he didn't go to prison for that,
brother. No, that's not what he went
for. No, that wasn't it. It was for
sledgehammering his father. But let's
not talk about that. Let's focus on
here. One of the reasons I suspect,
let me get everything ready. I just got
to make sure that Muhammad Hijab is
dying to debate now.
Not because
he can refute my arguments. He knows I'm
going to bury him because he's going to
manifest like a dog like he did with
Christian Prince. You remember when
Christian Prince called in his liveream
him and Ali Dawa started shouting over
Christian Prince, cutting him off,
yelling over him, manifesting.
He was manifesting foaming like his
prophet because the same demon that
possessed Muhammad is possessing them
and filling them. Yeah, I know that they
he did a video 33 minutes. I didn't
watch it, but that's nonetheless the
video was done because now he has to
address it because it's become much more
major than I think David would realize.
That's what I think happened. The fact
that he had to do a video, they told me,
means it became so serious and such a
major issue he had to now address it.
That's why I think he did it. But
nonetheless, let's focus. Let me get to
the point.
So my suspicion was that Muhammad wanted
to then throw David Wood's past in his
face and my past in my face. And the
slanderous lie, the defaming lie about
supposedly me graing my ex-wife never
happened. A lie from the pit of hell.
The Lord Jesus have mercy on all of us.
Right? Things you say, you may think
they don't have consequence for the
future. But nonetheless,
I think that's why he wanted to do it.
Let me get out of the screen, man. Hold
on. Let me get the hell out of the
screen.
I think that's why I wanted He didn't
want to debate. He wanted to manifest.
So, Muhammad, I'm warning you, buddy. If
you are man enough to debate me, you go
that route, I will expose, humilate your
prophet because hijab,
your prophet is in hell. He's dead. He's
under the feet of Christ. Jesus is
alive. He's almighty. There's not a damn
thing you can do about it. I can even
use your Quran to show that Jesus is
better than your Muhammad. And that
David Wood is better than your Muhammad.
I'm better [clears throat] than
Muhammad. David Wood [cough]
and I
because of Jesus Christ are better than
Muhammad who's under our feet because of
Jesus. So what did Mimiab do? He started
manifesting. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. YOU KNOW,
YOU FINISH, BOY. You finish. HAHA. BE
STRONG. LIKE DAVID WOOD perfectly
perfectly imitates the great ape, right?
The great ape mcgilliga gorilla
me.
YEAH, YOU FINISHED, BOY. YOU finish
me boy. Anyway,
coming back to the issue.
I'm going to warn you, Mimi Nab, you
dare talk about David's past or my
mistakes, I'm going to your prophet and
I'm going to show you that by your
criteria you're condemning Muhammad
who's already so Daniel Pigu that's why
I went on his Twitter and said hey buddy
you want PBD to ask me about my
supposedly my wife well I was acting
like your dog Muhammad so are you saying
he's wrong because that day I took
shiada so I'm going to turn it against
them
I'm going to turn it against him you
talk about us I'm going to talk about
your prophet turning against you mock us
every argument you against me and David,
I'm going to turn against Muhammad.
Because when David did what he did
before he was a Christian, he was acting
like Muhammad but better. What do I
mean? David did not do these things as a
Christian. He condemns those acts that
he did. David realize now because he is
born of the spirit that he wasn't being
Christlike, but he was being Muslim.
He was being Muslim. In fact, he was
better than your prophet because your
prophet
nine-year-old at least David said was 15
and 13 older than Aisha and they were
not playing with dolls. So that means
even in the world when David was
unregenerate and not a Christian, he was
still better than your prophet.
So if you're going to condemn David, you
just buried Muhammad. Likewise, when I
my ex-wife back, I wasn't being
Christlike. See, but David and I have a
standard. When I reacted and I hit, and
I'm not trying to justify it. I sinned.
I know I did. I made a mistake, right?
Pray for me. I don't have control.
But when I my ex-wife, I was behaving
like Muhammad.
Yeah, that's another thing. David was
18. Muhammad was 54. So even in the
world, David was better than Muhammad
when he wasn't a Christian.
You understand my point?
Even in the world, David was better than
Muhammad.
Better when he wasn't a Christian. How
much better is David now to Muhammad
that he's a Christian?
You with me there?